so you guys have heard me talk endlessly
about our cognitive frameworks our
frameworks of interpretation our lenses
of interpretation and how they end up
governing our experience of the world
and so I thought today we talked about
whether there can be a silver lining a
kind of poetry in romantic rejection I
am a big time lover of love I am a
sentimentalist and a romantic and I have
definitely been sold on the idea that
romantic love is an identity affirming
mechanism you end up seeing yourself
reflected in the iris of a lovers eye
and they raise you up to the light and
so of course there is a crushing fall
from grace when the object of your
affection rejects right to be told no
from someone you've put on a pedestal is
to be the gate of your entire character
structure is called into question your
entire house of cards
potentially may collapse
romantic rejection is a difficult pill
to swallow no matter the circumstances
but perhaps there is some semblance of
poetry to be found perhaps there is some
beauty to be taken from being told no I
don't want to be with you I'm reminded
of a line from the film of Vanilla Sky
where the best friend of the main
character who always gets a girl tells
him
we'll never know these guy who knows
because without the bitter baby the
sweet penis
that definitely resonates right this
whole paradoxical idea of knowing the
exquisite pain guy who goes home alone
how could pain ever be exquisite right
how could something that aches
how could a ghoulish somehow be
beautiful right and it makes me think of
a sad song it makes me think of
beautiful melodies that make us cry
right the agony and the ecstasy are
sometimes two sides of the same coin and
this notion of contrast right without
the bitter baby the sweet eight has the
sweet so perhaps from this we can learn
and apply in our lives that when things
don't go our way when the ones we love
tell us no way take that in we accept it
with grace we feel the ache
in gratitude
I know for me I take that and rework it
into a work of art take that pain I take
that sorrow I take that wistful longing
for what might have been and what could
have been and what should have been turn
it into poetry this is what we can
strive for
you